now bruce asks a much broader question
can a social structure be virtuous or
unvirtuous
aristotle um
doesn't
really
consider this uh i mean he talks about
social structures and the social
structures that he has in mind are
city-states police right or parts of the
police
they can be
virtuous in the sense that like their
their people are virtuous right
they could be virtuous in the sense that
justice prevails throughout them you
know justices we're going to talk about
it
later on in in book five
and they they could be
geared well towards promoting virtue
which which requires some work right
it's not like you can just set up the
laws and boom everybody becomes virtuous
by following them there's a constant
process of education and adjustment
that's taken that that needs to take
place
um
in the politics aristotle also basically
says every single existing greek
city-state
is
not well governed
so
and and many of them have bad
constitutions
so
he's pretty pessimistic about that i i
don't think that aristotle himself so
here's a good distinction i don't think
that aristotle himself would say that
a social structure itself is virtuous or
vicious
but
i don't know that we
we have to stick with that i think that
we could
say that some are but we also have to be
very careful because it's
it's easy to be mistaken about whether
our society is virtuous or or vicious
right
will says the world is full of people
who lack virtue who are just sheep
acting accordingly because it's what's
expected under the circumstances
yeah i mean and that's basically what
every virtue ethicist would say the the
key is not to
you know lament that or you know allow
that to get to us but to figure out how
you
offer the possibility of becoming
virtuous and how you like you know
weed out the crappy
um gives a little nod to virtue but
isn't really about virtue stuff there's
lots of virtue ethics curricula out
there that are really no good you know
because all they do is like they've got
a bunch of cards that they give to kids
and they're like here's your courage
card we'll give this to you when you
demonstrate courage but they don't have
what aristotle has which is or the
stoics or plato
identifying what goes into it actually
right
steve says as a person who's reading
this text
or any text by aristotle for the first
time
i'm fascinated and surprised how he
makes statements that with our current
sensibilities we see as questionable
i fully recognize that he was writing
this stuff a couple millennia ago so i
appreciate a lot less information to
work with then but it is still really
interesting and surprising to me
i mean it shouldn't be that surprising
when you look at the field of um feel
the domains of like popular psychology
and self-help and personal development
because there's people saying all sorts
of stuff that's much less plausible than
what aristotle is saying all the time
in in those areas and there are people
who live in the same present as
as us
you're going to find that i think here's
a broader thing
any any person that you're gonna read um
from
virtue ethics philosophy in general
there's gonna be some things where
you're like yeah yeah that makes that
makes sense and then there'll be other
things we're like
what were they thinking
when they said that and then sometimes
it'll be just like wow that was like a
mind fart on their part you know i have
no clue what the hell they're saying and
then there'll be other things where
you're like oh okay now that i read this
other thing i see how why they arrived
at this this point of view
i kind of think that when it comes to
the
long argument there that temperance does
not apply to any of our
mental pleasures nor does it apply to
pleasures of
sight hearing and smell nor does it
apply to the refined pleasure sometimes
i think iris will just off face you know
so
steve
asks
or says i'd agree you can be really
afraid totally devoid of confidence and
do the action anyway i'm reading it
right that aristotle doesn't count that
as courageous
yeah i mean that would be what we call
self-controlled where you make yourself
do the thing that is
along the lines of a virtuous person but
you don't yet have a virtuous
disposition if you're like really scared
crapless as we say and yet you still
manage to make yourself like do the
thing that you need to do
you're not courageous but you're on the
way to courage doing that sort of thing
helps us out
to become courageous and so that's you
know it's it's still a good thing it's
still valued it's just not as good as
having the disposition
of courage and you know another thing
that comes across
that aristotle doesn't talk about this
way but i think i think is well worth
bringing up the courageous person as
courageous
is going to
do so across
different domains right
so
if they're um afraid of public speaking
and they manage to get themselves okay
with doing public speaking big problem
for many academics by the way it wasn't
really that much of a problem for me um
but but it is for for many others um and
then you know you you become courageous
there you can also probably become
courageous when it comes to dealing with
bullies
or
going into a negotiation
with you know about a house
or
um giving
illness or you know
dealing with other things that require
us to to handle fear and i think there's
a lot of things
that are that are
requiring courage from us
we'll take nicole's first
because i think this is a good example
of somebody who exceeds in fearlessness
the way that aristotle's talking about a
soldier who is on drugs fighting could
be an example of that
yeah i mean if you um as as the
nazis apparently did in world war ii
gave you know amphetamines felt like
they were candy and then people get all
amped up and they you know they they
feel more confident on the one hand and
they all it also suppresses fear
then they can go and do things that they
wouldn't ordinarily uh do because they
you know otherwise they would they would
be afraid of dying yeah i think that's a
good example or you know you have um
strange cases of people very very rare
who don't actually feel pain
or feel the feeling of fear
and
it could be due to you know
brain issues it could be due to trauma
i think that is a
a prime example as well
um malcolm can you be courageous in the
face of death if you believe in a
positive afterlife yeah sure i mean why
not
uh being courageous means braving you
know difficult scary situations
for some greater you know good
um
maintaining your relationship with the
divine
could be one of those sorts of things
right
a lot of people you know we have to say
about belief how how what kind of belief
do you have do you have a
quasi-cartoonish belief
that you know you're going to be
welcomed into a heaven with angels and
harps you know sitting around doing
nothing all day in the clouds that might
not be that great of a motivator right
and as we get closer to to death that's
when these like belief in a positive
afterlife would really kind of kind of
pay off right we would see what that
belief amounts to
nicole you mentioned a person who has a
winning streak but runs away when they
fail is pseudo-courageous it seems oh
here's a good one it seems a person with
a losing streak learned helplessness but
still acts as more courageous in that
context
yeah and i like that
more courageous right not
is simply courageous is moving towards
courage
and
a person who's got a losing streak like
that and has learned helplessness
might also
appear
cowardly right and maybe it's not
genuine cowardice
but maybe it is like you're saying
learned helplessness
daniel if i hate my job and so i see
getting fired is fine in this
circumstance even though i normally
would fear being fired would aristotle
see that as being courageous no i don't
i don't think he'd see that as
being courageous but again it could be
like on the way to being
courageous right um
i was just earlier today you've probably
all seen on twitter that comedian
who
um
it started out with him doing tic tac
things where he's like working in an
ikea and people ask him dumb questions
and then he responds boldly to them
that would be kind of along the same
lines i don't i don't think that that
would necessarily be courage but here's
the here's kind of the cool thing
aristotle thinks that the things that
are not
the virtue itself
they provide us with
raw material that we can work with right
so let's say you and i are like hanging
out
uh
having coffee after you've like walked
off the job right
and you're like i screw that place and
then we start talking about it
um you know your motives would start
coming to light your your general uh
structure of how you approach things
would start coming to light and maybe
that helps you to become
courageous eventually i mean we we do in
fact especially in our times have a lot
of fear
and and often rightly so when it comes
to jobs career the economy
um
savings all of these matters that are
concerned with money and we're going to
talk about them a bit more in um
two weeks yeah two weeks when we talk
about
um
generosity or liberality and
magnificence which have to do with
expenses
so would somebody still be courageous if
they stood up to a bully
but they couldn't manage the punches
they received so they stood up against
the bully but did not adequately make it
through the circumstance
i mean i think aristotle would say that
um
[Music]
yes and no i mean
so
standing up against the punches meaning
like being able to
continue to function and not like say oh
i give in you know do whatever you want
um i mean getting the crap beaten out of
you is kind of scary and i mean this is
part of why in martial arts they have
you do they have you get used to getting
hit right so you realize that it's it's
not quite so bad and that could fit in
with these facsimiles right so the
experienced person
gets hit
and um
realizes that
that um
their uh
you know
body is in jeopardy but they can make it
through that sort of thing
it's not really not quite so bad they
can keep you know punching back or
something like that whereas the person
who has no experience
there's that old old mike tyson quip
right everybody's got a plan until they
get punched in the face
okay that's a good test of like whether
you
really have developed uh courage within
you
yeah
um here's a question in the q a from
will would aristotle consider the 9 11
hijackers to be courageous
i mean i don't think so i think it would
depend very much on the um
on the account of of what right uh to
try to inflict i don't think that
terrorism in general is going to involve
uh an awful lot of courage and it's
interesting too because you could say
well they have to be courageous in order
to spread
terror to make other people uh afraid
and to place them into a situation
in which
fear will keep them from from doing
things um
i don't know i mean it would it would
really depend on we'd have to go into
like their motivations and their
motivations do not appear to be
particularly
um
noble you could say and then you go well
wait a second they're defending islam
well they're defending you know
a certain extreme
wahhabi-influenced uh interpretation of
it sure
but yeah i think terrorism in general
could involve something
that's kind of like courage but actually
is perhaps not right
um daniel they also seem to think it
would lead to good things for them
rather than just death and that's not
really that important and we don't
really know whether they thought that
they would
um
you know receive paradise or something
like that
[Music]
i mean if they did it just to go to you
know a wonderful sensual paradise
then
maybe it's not courage at all right it's
sort of like somebody who says i'm going
to be courageous so i can make them you
know i mean a million bucks doesn't
actually take you that far these days
it's a billion bucks right i'm going to
be courageous
um it's kind of funny because you think
about like
uh
a lot of people know joe rogan from his
podcast and and his his you know
let's just say interesting points of
view
and uh guess but he was i have a hard
time ever not thinking of him as the
fear factor guy right
where he had his big break where he
would get people to do things like you
know put their hand into a bunch of
cockroaches and could they could they
master it and why are they mastering it
um you know for ratings and a certain
kind of celebrity but also to make money
is that real courage
i mean i guess you could say well you
know if it's to pay for grandma's
operation and that's the only way to get
her operation yeah maybe that could be
courage but
contestants on game shows i don't think
are
showing an awful lot of
courage so the motive really plays an
important role
and aristotle points out and this is
going to go to a question that was asked
very early on
the activity of desire um increases with
matters that are connected with it so if
we indulge ourselves in stuff over and
over again our desires actually get
stronger that's something that plato
noted too in the republic
and so
he tells us that the epithelicone the
part of us that's desirous should be in
accordance with reason and this this
goes to some of the questions that were
asked a little bit earlier that is being
self-controlled
in the temperate person it goes beyond
just being in accordance with reason
like following reasonable guidelines
it's in harmony with reason some phoneme
it it you know it
cooperates with reason it's we might say
it it's integrated with reason so being
temperate uh is that way
now james says does aristotle actually
say children animals have no mind no he
doesn't say anything remotely like that
he says they're undiscriminating
right so the noose is the higher part of
the mind it's not just mind it's like
your intellect and
children um you know
this is developing in them and and they
have to learn how to discriminate
aristotle thinks that our human nature
doesn't just automatically unfold it
requires a lot of cultivation right
all right george has a good question
here it was a little unclear to me the
pain pleasure distinction
does zero subtle mean if you're
motivated solely by pain to avoid a
circumstance you don't have a good
reason to avoid that situation with
pleasure does he mean that indulging
yourself solely through pleasure is not
a good reason to indulge yourself in the
buffet
yeah i mean if the only reason that
you're trying to avoid pain is to avoid
pain that's that's not really a noble
reason
um
i mean aristotle would actually be more
inclined to say that we we shouldn't
avoid pain we should take on pain for
noble reasons right that's that's where
the courage part comes in
um
[Music]
and with pleasure does he mean indulging
yourself solely through pleasure is not
a good reason to indulge yourself in the
buffet i mean i think there are probably
some people who have that sort of
general idea i'm going to the golden
corral
golden corral if you don't know it's
sort of like the american
paradigm of a buffet restaurant you know
it's basically just a whole bunch of
buffets you walk in you pay your money
you can eat whatever you want to
um so
some people probably are like i'm gonna
go in there and i'm gonna enjoy the hell
out of this right i'm just gonna like
stuff myself i'll be there for three
hours you know i'll sit in my booth
and then uh you know um
uh
i'll eat some and then relax a bit and
then eat some more okay
there are probably some people like that
most people going there are like i am
here for the food you know and the taste
and stuff like that so it gets a little
bit more and they might even be like i'm
there to go to the beef station and get
that sliced beef that i like so much or
a super something like that
like that
james says could we consider aristotle a
pragmatist it seems like dewey is a kind
of aristotelian so no to both of those
pragmatism arises in the 19th century
um
dewey calls what he's doing
instrumentalism distinguishes it against
what james and purse
are are doing who are his predecessors
and dewey is not an aristotelian
you can always find similarities between
people but
dewey is doing his own his own shtick
right he's more influenced by german
idealism and um you know by the earlier
pragmatic uh thinkers and stuff like
that he considers aristotle basically
to be a example of somebody who's
misguided
when he brings him up
and so no aristotle's not a pragmatist
aristotle's an aristotelian it's better
to to see him in in his own
light
rather than to try to bring him into a
bad fit with another school which is
also kind of messy right whose
pragmatism are we talking about purses
james dewey schiller other people i mean
even maurice blondell got labeled a
pragmatist until he found out what
people at that time meant by it and then
he was like i'm not a pragmatist you
know so
what do you what do you find
is the most challenging for you
to be temperate in relation to i can say
that at various points in my life
you know smoking tobacco i used to smoke
a pack and a half a day because i got
started when i was 17 and then i joined
the army where there were no you know
state taxes and cigarettes were super
cheap and everybody smoked and then i
got out and you know uh worked in
restaurants where everybody smoked and
then went to college
at a time when you could still smoke in
public buildings that was pretty tough
for me to be tempered in and you could
also say you know
with what we now know about tobacco
and its effects on on the system is
there like a right amount or would the
right amount be no indulgence in that or
only every once in a very long while
like i'll have a cigar on my birthday
and that's that's pretty much it these
days we can also talk about you know
alcohol or other intoxicants
do we have to worry about being
self-indulgent when we're
engaging in
watching shows you know
we have we have unlimited opportunities
to watch as many shows as we want even
if we're just on youtube right we can
like spend time going down rabbit holes
maybe we need temperance when it comes
to that aristotle doesn't think that
falls under temperance maybe it does so
anyway
you